good morning believe nation today's
message is execute fast over to you neil
patel you need to execute and you need
to execute as fast as possible because
the thing at the end today is whether
you feel you have competitors or not
sooner or later you're gonna have
someone and if you can't move fast
enough
someone's gonna beat you to the punch so
make sure whatever you're doing you get
something out within a month or two if
it takes you longer than that you're
taking way too long
I created this company called surf and
it was in Rockwall Texas right by Dallas
and I had this brilliant idea have any
of you guys heard of the media temple
grid server solution that was my idea a
year or two before it came out
and I spent a million bucks on it trying
to actually do that idea before media
temple this funny thing is that I have a
million bucks so I actually had to
borrow a million bucks and I sped it
spent on business partners who moved
really slow and really weren't the best
at what they did within 12 months we
launched nothing they also had some of
the Proms in my previous slide right
like financial instability and they had
a family and kids of I think like six
so even bottom my home in Rockwall Texas
that cost two hundred and something
thousand why did I buy it instead of
renting it I have no clue no stupid and
young but nonetheless I lost over a
million bucks on that a borrowed money
non investor money but borrowed money
that I had to pay back and it failed
miserably because we never launched
anything if you can't along something
something like media tumbles gonna beat
you to the punch
get a ton of customers and make a lot of
money so lessons I learned from that set
deadlines no matter what you have to set
deadlines people have to be held
accountable to him as well right can't
just set deadlines it passes nothing
happens someone better be medium if not
you know something has to change you
also need to make sure they're small at
the deadline if they're like milestone
goals are too big for those deadlines
they're not gonna get met so make them
really small and tangible that way you
can see it really well in advance if
they're actually gonna be met or not and
last but not least don't worry about
perfection a lot of people like dude I'm
gonna create the most perfect version of
you know whatever it may be that
software has a lot of bugs nothing's
gonna be perfect perfection is overrated
nothing's ever perfect you're gonna
continue to have to iterate so forth so
on it's never gonna be perfect there's
always gonna be issues just get it out
there and start trying to make money so
I watch this video and I think about
Wayne Dyer whose quote was something
along the lines of a lot of people die
with their song still left in them
and I think it's so true I think
everybody has an idea in them everybody
has a business in them or song in them
or a book in them or something created
in them everybody has something in them
that they're not release and most people
die with that still within that most
people die within the regret of
wondering what could have happened right
you could be playing a bigger game right
now you look at your life you look at
the actions that you're taking you could
be playing a bigger game you could step
up and do more and push harder and
believe in yourself a little bit more
and take that idea that you have and get
it out of your head and get it off of
the paper and start actually doing
something about it I can't tell you how
many entrepreneurs I meet who come up to
me and say you know that idea for
whatever it is you know I had that idea
two years ago or three years ago or five
year that was my idea I had that idea
and they're upset that somebody else is
making millions of dollars while they're
still at this job that they hate because
they had this genius idea and they're
upset they feel that they're the ones
who deserve to make that money you don't
you don't deserve that money you didn't
do the work you didn't bet on yourself
you can't just sit here and complain
that somebody else took action you got
to actually go out and do the work and
so many of those people begin to get
stuck and that's their story for the
rest of their lives
that's their story of how like the
world's against them and they have all
these great ideas and they're never give
me the ones that make it rich that's
gonna be your story for the rest of your
life you got to get out of that if you
don't get the thing that's in your
that you think is such a fantastic idea
out into the world then you have nobody
to blame but yourself it's all on you
and that's the truth that kinda sucks
that kind of stings but it's also
positive because you can go up and do it
and the way through is to just start a
lot of people have this idea and they
think they have to come out here right
there's an ideal starting point they
think they got to come out here and they
don't know how to take that jump because
they see it as a giant leap right you
need the right team you need the money
you need the connections you need the
blah blah blah right you need all of
this stuff to get here and until you get
there you're not going to do anything
and that's the the surest way to failure
and to never getting anything off the
ground that's what most people do to get
there I need all of these things you set
up a thousand roadblocks in your way and
then what do you do when there's tons of
roadblocks you do zero because until
it's perfect you're not going to take
any kind of action just like trying to
find the perfect time to have a baby
doesn't exist there is no perfect time
there's no perfect time to get your idea
going now start do something instead of
waiting for $50,000 to start your thing
start now it's always much more about
the resourcefulness that you have than
the resources that you have so look at
that big vision that you have dream big
I love it
you big goal I love it now bring it back
to today what can I do in a small way
today to take some kind of action on my
idea and move it forward and then
tomorrow ask yourself the same question
the next year the same thing and those
little steps will add up to big steps to
help you move it forward the alternative
is you sit here and wait and do nothing
and complain and that thing that you
have in here dies with you so don't let
that be you execute fast do something
today move it forward and then again
again again again again so the question
today today is I'm curious what is the
story or was the story that you're
telling yourself that you feel that you
can't start until you get this what's do
this that you need until you can get
started on your idea I'm curious to
figure it out leave in the comments
below I'm going to join in the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day
I believe in you and hope you continue
to believe in your south and whatever
your one where it is I'll see you again
tomorrow warning for another shot